thanks everybody thanks for having us I
think as Michael said I wanted to
reiterate one thing that Michael said
that you know we're going to talk a lot
about tinkering and the work that we do
at the exploratorium around tinkering we
are not here to propose that we throw
out everything that you've ever learned
or every way that you ever learned as a
student or as a as a learner but we're
trying to provide some alternative and
some complimentary facet to the spectrum
of experiences that you might get as a
student over your lifetime through
lecture through hands-on activities
through demonstrations the the question
for us is what are we missing if we
don't have a chance or many
opportunities in our lifetime to engage
firsthand with science phenomenon art
related processes and tools materials
and other stuff and so really that's
what we have to share a little bit about
today with you when I would saying irony
is not lost a couple of things you're
gonna Park up a couple of things I'm
going to talk to you about our are just
kind of the reasons behind tinkering
like what what is it and why is it going
on at the exploratorium wise are all
this attention being given to it to us
tinkering and learning are so they're so
connected and we really believe in this
idea of constructionism that people
think differently when you're you're in
the act of actively making something so
a lot of what we have to offer really
does deal with physical stuff but I know
I know kind of a little bit about the
world that you're in I spent a lot of
time at the Media Lab and a lifelong
kindergarten group so a lot of times I'm
going to be talking physical but I think
a lot of those ideas actually apply in
the digital realm too um yeah I'm going
to read from this oh yeah here's a great
quote so that these two things yet to
green learning they're completely
intertwined but I think the idea behind
why offering this stuff is we really
want people to develop a tinker's
disposition we call it right we want you
to be able to confront something that
you don't necessarily know how to do and
the onset the outcome isn't
predetermined and you're going to be
able to maneuver through whatever it is
to get somewhere probably to have some
dead ends along the way follow some
strange tangents but this ability its
practice the more you do it the more you
tinker the better you get so the idea
that we're going to offer people these
experiences as a as a valid way of
learning we really see it as a serious
endeavor it's not just this fun
frivolous thing we get that a lot it is
fun it's definitely fun when people come
in to the museum though can you go back
for just yeah that's my cue that I'm
talking too much people do say a lot
like this is really fun but but what are
they learning right but twist that
around like right this looks like
learning but is it fun so anyway just
something to think about I think this is
a lovely quote from Mitchell Resnick
about the things that we're going to be
confronted with kind of the digital
natives of today or they change so
rapidly so let's not worry so much about
getting facts scientific facts kind of
learned by rote necessarily we do have
to have some of that but be able to
really think creatively about things and
tinker literally with kind of whatever
the environment is your is that you're
in whether it's elementary school or
graduate school or just life in general
pretty I think the maker movement is
really providing an amazing opportunity
have do you know about Maker Faire yes
if you don't I would encourage you to
get to San Mateo on the seventeenth and
eighteenth of next month but I feel like
this this insurgents now it's kind of in
the zeitgeist this attention being given
to DIY an appreciation for the handmade
and a lot of it had to do with make
magazine and these Maker Faires I feel
like it it provides an excellent
opportunity for the educational realm I
think we have to be careful of two
things one sometimes when i'll say this
primarily me when we educate
take this stuff on sometimes we we can
suck the joy out of things right so we
have to be careful with that because i
feel like the maker movement it really
builds on this incredible enthusiasm of
experts and novices coming together over
an incredible variety in terms of
background art science technology you
see it all kind of mashed up together um
anyway let me I just wanna make sure
yeah ah and I feel like you know you
asked the question what is what is
Stanford going to look like you know 20
years from now I would say the same
thing what are museums going to look
like I I feel like it's we're we're
poised to really change the way people
learn and anyway yeah I get all I get
all over excited about that so I want to
talk a little bit about tinkering and
making and the history of the Explorer
time I've have any of you been to the
old exploratorium the palace of fine
arts good what about the new one have
you been to the new building I encourage
you to go we're really proud of what
we've just put together and we feel like
the heart and soul transferred right to
this new building we've spent a lot of
time doing that but we're really proud
of that but tinkering and making is not
something new to the exploratorium or
too many museums in general historically
through the exhibit development process
artists residency's teacher institute
programs where teachers are actually
building and making things for their
classroom and the public programs will
bring in visitors and and other people
to share process and projects it's
always been part of the Explorer times
history and continues to be the question
that we have though is that all of the
preparation and the experimentation and
the exploration that the exhibit
developers and the artists and the
teachers would do kind of behind the
scenes weren't always present on the
museum floor you know is probably pretty
obvious that it's easier to use a spot
welder and a jigsaw in the shop than it
is to use on the museum floor but we ask
the question could we bring some tools
and materials and some long-term
explorations out into a space that we
call the tinkering studio so we'll talk
about the tinkering studio on how that
envelops some of the work that we're
we're talking about wait can you just
hang on that for a second so we were
talking with a few people over lunch in
the old space we
this they gave us the back corner it was
kind of where we did our first prototype
our proof of concept for the tinkering
studio now we're actually front and
center we are right when you get there
and in the beginning so we've grown a
lot in size so at the new at the new
exploratorium we've got a new space the
tinkering studio it's what we'll talk a
lot about the different activities that
we do but it's an environment that we
had to first of all kind of hide the
entrance to hear this is a space where
we were wanting a lot of people to come
in but spend a lot of time working on
projects so we couldn't work with
everybody at the Museum and we couldn't
welcome everybody at the first minute
that they come through the building so
we spent some time trying to carefully
design that space but it is a building
where we have loose parts tools and
materials that allow us to explore
different scientific phenomenon or
different artistic practices and we'll
show you a few of those I thought we'd
first start with a quick video from
something an experiment that we tried a
couple of years ago when we're trying to
prove this concept we held a series of
events called tinkering events and what
we tried to do is figure out could we
design activities on the museum floor
with loose parts and loose materials and
what would visitors actually do these
things were called open make so we sort
of we chose our themes ahead of time and
we would basically put out an all call
to all people that we knew instead we're
tackling this theme when you're it was
materials based it was like cardboard
plastic metal wire yeah would something
yeah and then one year it was everything
that started with T because we were the
tinkering studio toys trash tools and x
time yeah so what you're going to see is
about toys it's about three and a half
minutes right what I want you to do is
just see what you can recognize moments
of thinking and learning because you
might see a lot of technology you might
see a lot of loose parts toys and
materials but we really are trying to
figure out if we can create and
orchestrate these moments where people
are thinking and learning together
Oh
ready
this
don't poet slower
Oscar
too fast
still trying to get it to stand up by
itself
Oh
more like yeah
that's a perfect absolutely just know
all right then you want to attention on
your braces start off with this
operation on it quick it also be a dad
and like wiggle it a little bit now it
looks more like a lollipop
leg
Oh
sorry
manufacture of toys so temple this is a
first protec of this
and you can see that the difference in
paint job and the size and
boy we actually end up with enormous
dick in you can you feed on this side
you feed the wire in this side I'll feed
that wire on the other side are you
going to put some the scribblers on the
bottom
and with the code that we provide for it
you can actually give it like just any
music and it will detect the beat
yeah this is something
which takes advantage of the fact
can be used for either output or input
and then make it on the other side now
you wanna
hey
let's see how we're doing here
Oh
tuck
do this here
happy fourth
so for us the things that both at maker
faire I mean Maker Faire open make and
in the tinkering studio we look for and
sometimes get it wrong I mean a lot of
things that we offer you know they
they're not without their problems but
um if you took this Venn diagram and did
art science and technology we think that
sweet spot in the middle we almost
couldn't decide is this art is the
science is that is this technology we
like those things the most and try to
capitalize on those and have more of
those kinds of experiences offered so
but we also don't design these things
for kids I mean there are a lot of kids
that enjoy and work with these projects
with us but we're this is not a kid
based endeavor in terms of our design so
what I thought we would do is talk a
little bit about the design principles
that we have and then how that maps on
to some of the learning outcomes that
we're looking for so in the activities
that you saw on the other activities
that we do we break down our design
principles into three categories the
first is the activity design itself what
are the tools and the materials that we
bring to this endeavor and what are the
goals that we have in terms of meeting
people where they come in with their
knowledge and what's the scientific
content that we're hoping that they walk
away with or the scientific process
skills we also choose materials that are
inviting or or engaging in some
immediate way and actually continue to
work in that way as you can plexus is
and what's most important for us is that
we're not trying to bring everybody in
and give them the quickest step-by-step
resolution to what they don't know by
saying this is the best explanation for
you we're trying to provide multiple
pathways in and through these
explorations so that three different
people might explore the activity in
slightly different ways based on what
they come in thinking about their
experience in that moment with other
people and then what they might bring to
it next time and I would just want to
point out this one the stem is a means
not an end I mean a lot of people come
to us for professional development work
and their goal is to do stem work in
their classroom we feel like tinkering
is a way to get you there but it's it
really truly is about the me
and not like stem as the goal so
facilitation is other category that we
carefully pay attention to all of the
activities that we have in the tinkering
studio on the museum floor are
facilitated by ourselves or explainers
these are teenage and college-age
students who come in and they get a lot
of training from us and they're the
facilitators there are the people who
are guiding and helping people through
these explorations some of the things
that we pay attention to as we're
designing activities is in terms of
facilitation how do we welcome people
and what's the initial spark that might
get people interested in doing something
once they've started working on a
project how do we sustain them you know
how we were talking about getting people
going and sometimes it can be really
frustrating if you don't know what your
next step is going to be so we help
people through that next step oftentimes
you might you might you know you might
figure out how to hook up a wire and a
battery and a bald in an unexpected way
that happened by accident and so then as
a facilitator we can step in kind of
check your knowledge to make sure that
if it was an accident there are other
opportunities and other materials that
we can offer to help that and then
finally an environment it's an important
one for us and here this is again where
it's kind of physical digital are very
connected to me but what what can you do
in an environment that makes people
comfortable makes people comfortable
with coming in and not necessarily
knowing so how can you can the
environment be shaped so tentative ideas
can be tried out I mean I don't yeah
okay i won't go down that path i'll say
something about this later but i also
feel like this ways for you to come into
a social space whether it's online or in
the museum that would allow for
cross-fertilization of ideas also is
another kind of interesting territory to
be in and I think that environment goes
a long way you know there are just a
couple of us for 30 or 50 people so two
facilitators are not going to be able to
spend the entire 40 or 50 minutes with
each individual learner so how do we
create an environment in such a way
where people are situated around the
work tables and start facilitating each
other as they develop new ideas or as
they make new insights so trying to
figure out what that environment is that
sort of encourages this collective
sharing of ideas through the process
and what can I say just one more thing I
think also having an opportunity for
people to feel like they do have a sense
of autonomy and they're kind of working
on their idea but they're also
participating in something larger than
themselves I think is good so then the
design principles go so far in terms of
our goals for the activity but the
question for our team is also what are
our goals about education what are the
educational outcomes that we hope to get
to and so we've spent some time talking
about this we've broke them down into
four for big ideas first of all how do
we think about getting people engaged in
these things sometimes they come in with
a proclivity to start working on a
project and sometimes we have to have
the hundred thousand toothpicks
sculpture that Scott Weaver's been
working on for 37 years it's so
outlandish that people become engaged
just because of that fact what is it
through the activity where we can
support learners to take their own
initiative and build and construct with
real intentionality how do we develop
like we were just discussing that social
scaffold within the environment so that
people can actually support one another
and finally even though ninety percent
of schools and curriculum are focused on
development of understanding for the
content or more this work right yes my
understanding we're not leaving it out
we do have a goal that people are going
to understand more about circuits or
light color and sound or mechanics when
they leave but it's just part of the
overall set of learning dimensions that
we have curriculum usually the thing to
start with is just number four there
what are your running bolts we are
things that some can be being able to
save or accomplish and the top three
feels me much more like the kinds of
things that you would associate with
many other kinds of activities and I'm
wondering is this is this something you
brought to the table is this something
that you that you're drawing together
like certain or be museum kind of
perspective you know it feels to me like
so the design principles were sort of as
we're developing something to try out on
the floor we try to hit a lot of those
things and when people are engaged
one of those activities we came up with
ways of describing kind of the behaviors
we were looking for and that's where the
learning dimensions comes in and I think
with each one of these will see some in
a minute but I think each one of those
to us was our in Gaul you'll kind of
you'll kind of see more along each one
of those but I think the words
development of understanding was also
really critical because getting straight
to that content goal is not necessarily
our article and I don't think anybody
can truly develop an understanding or
change their knowing about something
without a social endeavor of some sort
without intentionally practicing and
exploring this work for themselves or
becoming personally engaged in that
process however if you never get here if
you never develop an understanding about
this content that we're wanting to offer
I mean we can we can engage and
entertain people until we're blue in the
face but if it doesn't get to the point
where you're actually complexities and
shifting your understanding about
something it's an activity that doesn't
have as much meaning for us as one that
actually hits all of these things so
then what are the indicators for us as
we're facilitating and designing these
spaces what is it about each of those
for learning dimensions that when
visitors are with us indicate that
something interesting and important is
happening and so we'll break it down
just a little bit for each one um yes oh
well Mike was just saying the spending
time I mean that's definitely part of it
but that's we want more than that you
know it's great that people want to
spend time in the tinkering studio but
if you follow kind of engagement down to
the next level we also believe that
another indicator of that is really
showing motivation and interest and what
does that look like so it looks like not
sure what that emotion is that's going
on there but definitely motivated
sometimes it's kind of joy and pride and
you'll hear it in what people say but
it's a connection or kind of a reason
that they're compelled to kind of keep
going with their investigation and again
being personally engaged in this is
really important because very quickly if
you're pushing on your thinking you
might become frustrated at the
fuzziness that you're moving into an
example might be if you come in and
start working with circuit boards with
us and you're connecting batteries two
bulbs using wires you might get that
pretty quickly but when I enter a new
idea and ask you to you know integrate a
switch or to make three light bulbs turn
on a set of just one that becomes a
little bit of a challenge and I think
pushes against some people's
understanding if you're not truly
engaged and interested in solving that
problem I think it's really hard to push
your ideas to that next level and the
initiative and intentionality we kind of
this is kind of still going in kind of a
hierarchy of things we want people to
come into the space and be able to set
their own goals not necessarily have
that coming from us you know this is a
great example she was working with sewn
circuits to create this bracelet and had
some working knowledge of circuits in
the beginning but by the time she left
it was a much deeper and yes she was
quite proud this is another sort of idea
about intentionality and persisting in
this problem space way one of the things
that we try to do is offer complex
challenges or complex activities that
actually force you to want to persist in
building through that that on that
moment so scott weaver is a fellow has
been working for 35 years in his living
room constructing a city of san
francisco out of toothpicks and we've
headed at the exploratorium for the last
couple of years and the interesting
thing to us is for us this piece looks
done I mean after 35 years and a hundred
thousand toothpicks you'd think that
this piece is finished he comes in every
other week to interact with the public
but has been spending more and more time
lately with his back to the public
continuing to work on his piece so what
is it about the compelling and sort of
engagement level that we can design into
these activities that allow people of
all ages and backgrounds to be great
delight at this point is sort of
tongue-in-cheek I mean we do want
opportunities that allow people to
pursue it persist in the problem space
but um I think for us with Scott the
cool thing about it for me is we get to
offer a platform for him to come and
share his work I met him walking across
the parking lot at a grocery store near
my house he's the produce manager there
he was wearing a toothpick hat I mean I
definitely my my radar is tuned now I
look for makers and tinker's all the
time but I'm you know we struck up a
conversation and come to find out he had
this nine-foot by nine foot sculpture
that he called rolling through the bay
it's an homage to San Francisco but it's
more than just a toothpick sculpture
there are seven different runs that you
can stick a ping-pong ball down and it
takes a tour of San Francisco and it'll
take you through different areas of San
Francisco anyway I absolutely love that
it's there at the Museum offers him a
place to share his work and for other
people to appreciate it and I also as
Mike was saying he literally is still
going he built this whole thing for the
49ers and when we lost he didn't put it
on but he just added sutro towers just
last weekend a couple of other things
another thing about the intentionality
you know again these are the indicators
these are what people are saying and
doing when we're noticing that these
activities are working for us and so one
of the things that we often try to
figure out is how can we support people
to take intellectual risks it's not so
easy for young people but especially
difficult for adults to be comfortable
not knowing something so what is it
about the environment or our
facilitation or the activity itself that
allows people to take an intellectual
risk to go someplace where they're not
comfortable going because as an adult
you're supposed to know the answers but
the other thing that we do is we sort of
parallel that with risk-taking in terms
of mess in danger and using real tools
and real materials you know this is a
portable spot welder that we're using to
solder together lengths of wire on the
museum floor this had never been done
before at the exploratorium we had to
get more permits than you can imagine
but it was worth it because we had young
men and women coming in and spot welding
alongside parents who actually showed up
that day because their job is as a spot
welder and they wanted to share that
experience with each other the other
fascinating thing about taking
intellectual and even personal risks
with some of these things is that we
don't shy away from danger we use hot
glue guns and sharp knives and lots of
lots of power tools on the floor in safe
ways but we want to get people their
first encounter sometimes with
these tools in an environment that's
purposeful and supported and it's
fascinating to watch how much more
careful kids are with real tools in real
danger than even adults or some of us
are at times but the intellectual risks
that Mike is talking about our kind of
showing intellectual courage it's the
kind of thing we mean is when you're
when you're working around a table and
somebody sort of asserts an idea that is
in disagreement with someone next to
them you know having that confidence to
say no I don't really think that's the
way that works it's it's that kind of
thing social scaffolding the museum is a
social space the tinkering studio is
social space on steroids you work really
close to each other this example on the
right is marble machines and it's it's
basically pegboard from home depot and
stuff you can get molding and pipes and
tube and stuff like that you're just
building kind of runs for marbles the
thing I love about it is lots of people
crowd around and work on this thing and
often end up working with people that
they didn't come into the museum with
that's not something we see in other
parts of the museum so I find it really
interesting and they're also not afraid
to sort of look at something that's not
working even stating it out loud and
then someone will quickly come over and
join in their investigation right along
with them we spend a lot of time
thinking about environments and also
activities that support the social
scaffolding so when we pee when we see
visitors who didn't come in together
actually sharing ideas and helping each
other out it's a really important moment
that we look at and try to figure out
what's going on here sometimes we're
very purposeful with the activity you
saw the the marble runs is one way where
you can enter an environment and
everybody's building marble runs this is
an activity that we're trying right now
called light play it's a slow moving
motor and some interesting LEDs that
actually creates light and shadow
kinetic sculptures on these small
portable screens so small groups you
know two three at a time will come in
and construct little light play
vignettes and this is all about geometry
of light shadows the distance between
the light source and the shadow maker
and the screen but it's also it's an
evocative and sort of beautiful outcome
that you end up building when you're
finished but you're not taking it home
many of the things that we build you're
not taking home you're actually leaving
behind for other visitors
to come in and start working on after
you or in this case all of the
individual screens are placed into a
large cabinet in the back so behind that
that I'm the child and the woman there
are 15 spaces for different lighting
it's for you to actually contribute your
contraption to the rest of the museum in
that way and then let new people come in
to take a look at what's been done
before you and maybe get some ideas
about what what to happen next and
here's more about the development under
under standing to us it um learning
isn't linear and it's not terminal you
don't get to this point you're like okay
I know this now we often see a lot of
kind of development happening when
people are going to talk about or
express a realization through a factor
utterances and what we mean by that is
kind of you'll you'll see somebody
working in there like oh I get it that's
connected you know what you'll you'll
hear it you you see it too in their body
language that's kind of the initial
development of understanding and we we
really we try to either highlight
mention those and passing kind of get
other people kind of into those
investigations together by what though
what they're saying and some of the
under indicators the other thing that we
see visitors doing a lot is sharing
explanations with each other persisting
in that trouble space becoming
frustrated but actually pushing through
it because they just really want to
understand or as I mentioned before
really trying to figure out how we can
help people apply what they've just
explored to some new situation so I can
complexity and ask them to work together
a little bit people are very willing to
do that to actually try to figure out if
they can take something that they think
they understand and apply it to a
slightly different situation can I tell
them what that is yeah so we we have one
activity that's kind of on the other
side of the space going on when this
witness is happening wish I wish you
could really really see to truly
appreciate what's going on but it's an
activity called circuit boards so it's
basic kind of you would go to radioshack
pull or digikey pull these things off of
the shelf put them in the table in front
of you and start
King things up there's no kind of set
instructions or step by step direction
it's really kind of what part interest
you and can you figure it out and we've
done a lot of activities where it's toid
I section you know like the Elmo doll
with that kid like how do you take apart
a mechanical toy to the point where it
still works but you've got it in as many
pieces as possible a real purposeful
dissection activity so what I love about
this one we have these adult lights now
so every Thursday we're open from six to
ten for adults only and the first one of
the month we kind of do these blowout
events february's was sexplanations you
know is valentines time so um what is
happening here is a local store good
vibrations donated some equipment and
this young lady with the purple hair on
the right is talking about some
experience that she's had with this
equipment and it has to do directly with
the circuit boards so they're talking
about reasons for motors that are strong
vibrations that are more noticeable and
less noticeable I mean I was turning
every shade of red I was totally
embarrassed throughout this this
investigation but it was one of those
incredible moments like she was really
applying direct experience with her
experience there on the floor of the
museum we don't do sex toy dissections
every night but we can they're just one
sort of summary statement and this comes
from a colleague and mentor to us Paul
tad or who if there's there's anything
that we're really trying to say here
through all the design focus and the
learning indicators it's it's something
like this I mean suppose that we assume
that the purpose of learning and
education is not just to remember a lot
of things or to provide a product that's
what a lot of the maker movement is
about this building this step-by-step
product but rather if education is about
changing one's life and people changing
their lives meanings that they're
changing the relationships with each
other the things that they're
interacting with and with their
understanding of who they are themselves
if learning has to do with the meanings
of things I think this has allow a lot
to do with design and thinking about
interface if learning has to do with the
meanings of things and those meanings
have to do with the uses of those things
in our lives well then the meaning is in
the use is the
you wanna talk about this yeah so if
something connected that we were saying
with you and kind of resonated with you
we want to know about it look us up we
actually just came out with a book
called the art of tinkering that talks
more about a lot of the work that we do
with our artists and scientists and
residents it's filled with a collection
of kind of high and low tech approaches
that are kind of part wenzel whimsical
and wonderful but I'm I have a couple
books up here that you can come and
check out if you want it has conductive
ink on its cover which we absolutely
love since a lot of the stuff we do has
to do with circuits we wanted people to
tinker directly with the book and I'll
say one other thing we're offering a
MOOC through Coursera that starts in
June on the twenty-second we're
skeptical about this we don't quite know
how to green is going to translate to
this environment but it's called the
fundamentals of tinkering and it's going
to be a six-week course to dive into the
world of circuits through tinkering
thank you can we take some questions
yeah okay so we have seized up a lot of
this is relatively a high touch point so
you you know that you noted that you had
a number of volunteers coming in and
asking questions and this is something
that has been on my mom recently where
say courses in HCI that were originally
designed for 30 people now are limiting
enrollment at 80 and we have to back up
and say are we being as effective as
educators and engaging people with up in
conversation with materials at that
scale and I'm wondering if you have any
thoughts or advice now at lunch you that
basically said our solution is to get
fewer people into the room now we feel
this tension between we want as many
people who want to learn this we want to
let them be able to do so or i can just
cut out half people from the class and
say you're gonna have the
experience and everyone else gets zero
so are there ways to scale this is it
just your volunteers what do you do here
no nothing volunteers but I mean it's a
good question you know we were also
talking about lunch we shared the
tinkering studio over in Saudi Arabia
and there are places that are interested
in this work that we won't be able to
reach physically and I think the high
touch point is definitely a part of it
we takes time and it takes people
working through this stuff but I think I
think there is a way that you can scale
it up in terms of kind of it's almost
like a grassroots enthusiasm that's
building and I think is a combination I
think it's going to be a combination of
kind of volunteer time that might come
in the form of parents you know kind of
social groups hackerspaces clubs things
like that nannies we actually have
nannies that are coming to the tinkering
studio as a group they call it nanny
camp and they're they're coming together
to spend some time in this place but i
think what what is really doing it it's
tapping into personal interest and
trying to connect folks in a way either
whether it's kind of who they are and
what they do in their professional world
or how they like to spend their time you
know outside of that work and so I mean
I would echo that same sentiment I think
this is about a distributed idea that
first of all we didn't invent we didn't
start this this has been happening for
eons and multiple cultures and multiple
parts of the world I think what we're
doing is through the exploratorium is
we're saying we think this is important
and we're giving some formed how that
might happen in a museum with the hopes
that we don't have to go to every museum
to make it happen but other educators
other artists and other makers will
actually take this on and start their
own grassroots effort in their community
centers or at their schools are at their
homes and so the kitchen table I mean I
want to see tinkering studios everywhere
not it's it's a it's an approach as much
as it is a physical space you'd rather
see a thousand small groups work on this
then work with a thousand people in one
space at one time ago
again yeah so keeping the tinkers really
interacted and I think physical
sometimes too are you planning on
developing that yeah I wish you know it
keeps me up at night actually so what
we're trying to really do is we develop
right right now we're in the process of
shooting lots of video and stuff that
we're going to be sharing some of it is
going to be just this raw kind of canned
footage but then it's how do you support
this and get people really talking about
it and trying stuff out we've talked
about if we can't really require people
to buy something reply require people to
actually do something right this is part
of what Coursera has a constraint that
they've given us then what what can we
give them that is close to an experience
at the exploratorium as possible now I'm
hearing myself say this and at the same
time I'm like look like I don't want
anything to do it but I actually do I
feel like there are people out there
that even if they can't access these
materials they can see we're going to
give them a chances to really see raw
footage of what some of this stuff looks
like in the tinkering studio and in
Colorados adding community centers right
and really dig into what's the
difference what's tinkering what's
engineering you know what what are what
are those differences engineering making
tinkering when do you see stuff
happening that you think is rich and why
what's the evidence for what you see is
going on and then we're also talking to
classroom teachers that we've been
working with we've we've actually sent
some of these tinkering activities out
to them I think their words speak much
louder than ours when they say things
like you know my students have never
responded this way when I've taught this
subject matter in the past so I'm
excited about that we are really going
to try to get people to do this stuff
because we really believe it is so much
about the stuff so we're choosing some
things that have we hope low enough
threshold or barriers to entry that they
can actually scrounge the stuff and get
tinkering and then we'll try to have
these talk about sessions just kind of
break out over the MOOC to get to get
people either through affinity groups
we're not quite sure I mean
all of this is really to say this is a
big experiment for us but we we feel
like we have a community of practice
that we just developed opened in last
fall we've got 190 museums around the
world that now are interested in this
making and tinkering idea so it's taking
lots of different shapes and lots of
different places but we're connected and
that we're trying to do similar things
for folks so I I don't know it feels
like it feels like it's important to try
even though I'm really skeptical about
it yes which I'm hearing and tinkering
with different how do you grade a
temporary class yeah these are some
really profound questions that we're
trying to figure out and you know by the
time you do this five times we may have
a better answer so we're gonna give it
our basket yes okay have you tried a
number of ways for people to bring their
results of their tinkering and their
tinkering problems and so on into the
exploratory because you know a
significant a current project may take
weeks months exactly absolutely one of
the designs of the environment is that
is a repository of projects that people
either construct and build at the
exploratorium or might bring from home
or we might ask them to bring and share
in the context of the activity so when
we're doing a bunch of sone circuit and
paper circuit electronic greeting cards
will ask people to bring in the things
that they're working on are the things
that they've created so we can share
them alongside other visitors that are
building things but even better than
that we're trying to give these ideas
away as any way we can so we hand out a
flyer that says here here's the PDF so
you can go home and make your own marble
board if you go to home depot or go
online because we have this project cat
encapsulated in some sort of you know
activity guide and what we find is that
many many people do this they go back
and they start building their own
contraptions at home and then they end
up coming back to us repeatedly because
they have further questions about how
something is built or they want to try
out the component that they built at
home on the marble board at the
exploratorium and I think a lot of that
has to do with the fact that we're there
in the space with the visitors we now
represent a different facet of the
exploratorium and that we are people who
are deeply curious and interested
in what the visitors are bringing to us
and we could to know them by their first
names and they know us by their first
names so there's a relationship that
builds its really profound in that way
and but also i mean i would say we're
interested in online as well we teamed
up with science friday and we're
actually in the middle of this right now
so I want to encourage all of you if you
is hashtag machine art so the idea was
we wanted people to create something
that made art right and we sent this all
call out I guess two weeks ago it's
wrapping up Mike and I are going on the
show next week I can't believe the
submissions we're getting there's some
hilarious analog ones a guy hung a
pendulum from his sailboat and it drips
paint and you see so you like see him in
different conditions with different seas
that was a pretty funny one there's a
drone that creates I mean they're just
as creative as you can possibly imagine
I mean from kids doing these things two
adults two groups of hobbyists I mean I
absolutely love the things that people
are coming up with and the range I mean
there it's just so I want to do more of
that I feel like if right now it's all
aggregated on a rebel Mouse page that
science friday put together but I mean I
feel I would be very curious to know
that the people who are offering up
these submissions to this invitation
like do they feel connected with these
other folks we're going to be
interviewing some of the people that
have submitted things you know on air
but I'm encouraged by what I see there
to their their their challenge to us was
help us turn our listeners into doers to
makers to tinker's
yes granted I've never been to the
exploratorium such I this might have
just a question that would be answered
the moment I walking and you're going to
come a soon yeah but I'm kind of where
does for on where in your vision of the
exploratory Angus line with group for
nothing's working on the green space
where is the line between Boris pouring
tea green spaces and on the kind of
hacker spaces that are popping up all
sort of art affirming exploring
potentially and they are coding your
converse things yes I really feel like
constructing with cardboard and coding
those two things are both about
construction to me so I I welcome that
and I feel like for hackerspaces the the
thing I want people to do when they come
into the tinkering studio is kind of
just be turned on to this world that's
out there the crucible over in the East
Bay noisebridge in San Francisco like I
want them to connect with communities of
other folks so we bring them in to kind
of highlight their work and talk about
it and hopefully you know people will
you can even start up your own we've
done something with make in the past for
young makers which was also getting
clubs of kids making things in people's
garages kind of around the bay area but
there is some of a difference it's a
little different than hackerspaces or
tech shop for example I mean tech shop
is is where you can go to build out the
idea that you've developed and I think
that is an important place in the
ecology of this work I think tinkering
studio plays an important role in that
and actually before you get to tech shop
here's an opportunity for you to engage
with these types of tools and materials
for the first time and actually to
practice the development of an idea so
that you can bring it to tech shop and
produce that idea so we're not a
production shop we don't have rows of 3d
printers and rows of vinyl cutters but
we do have a few of those tools to
experiment in the context of meaningful
activities so that you can get a first
sense of it yeah i would say people in
general one myth kind of about tinkering
and making in museums that I run into
its this just throw about a bunch of
stuff out and then on the table and
something good will happen we do shape
it more than that we definitely kind of
pick a territory that we're
investigating but the richness really
comes not from in the variety of stuff
but the variety of people that are
interacting with that stuff oh yeah
there's a vending machine we do have a
vending machine so you know this is
another one this is this raging debate
in the book we have ways to get started
how do you tell people how to get
started without giving them a one two
three four so how do you offer a kit
that is open enough that allows for lots
of possibilities and not necessarily
that the things that you make in the kit
that you make in the kid that you make
in the kit are all going to be the same
it's not that those aren't cool I mean
I've done hundreds of those but that's
not really where our interests lies the
answer to your question we are trying to
develop some kits it's hilarious to
watch our development team debate about
kind of what to do because we're trying
to sell yogurt containers strawberry
baskets and hot glue I mean nothing more
than that no fancy packaging no sort of
excited little robotic text on it's the
real raw materials that we feel are
important to get you started with some
of these activities so there's sort of
an interesting uncut that we're trying
to push the weight at the same time so
the paper circuits GG I don't know if
any of you are familiar with her work
but she's a computer scientist at the
Media Lab she's done some cool work with
circuitries she's come up with this
thing called circuit stickers that
allows you to kind of play with
programming physically putting stickers
down on top of copper tape the copper
tape is slug tape you get it at home
depot to keep slugs out of your plants
so I want a kit that has that but at the
same time if you get totally into
soldering I want you to know about a
well or soldering iron so we have these
funny debates about kids need to be
cheap I'm like kids need to be good you
know yeah silly question was
I can imagine some science teachers
somewhere in some school wanting to do
this coming from the old textbook driven
learning experience and not knowing how
to introduce this into a classroom and
so the idea of a kit is less about the
things but a pedagogy or a program that
could be handed to them oh that I would
like to say we're gonna do it I hope I
hope people will leave with that because
we actually we get pretty meta we do
talk a lot of pedagogy about the stuff
but we offer you six ways to get started
that range in something you know if
you're going on the high computation and
it's how to work with Mickey Mickey's do
you guys know what making me he is with
students but then also like the
scribbling machines that Mike was
talking about yogurt cups and offset
motors but kind of a little fun part is
that we have like a little cooking show
motif it's like if you really want to
get started exploring simple circuits in
your classroom pull together some blocks
of wood these few components that you
might find in a dissected toy and here's
how we solder and build the component so
we do that in our regular professional
development workshops where teachers and
after school professionals come in and
actually physically build the parts that
they then take back to their classrooms
here's a way through the MOOC to try to
share that on a broader scale yes yeah
she's a show baby so she says I'm good I
think I real question I'm sitting here
thinking that what you do in a way is
phenomenon first learning which is
wonderful love it I love everything
about it and I'm also sitting here
thinking about the applicability of this
to to undergraduate education at this
university and and all of your
principles would work and be meaningful
and wonderful but the actual mutational
something like that would be incredibly
complex require you know when you talk
about about 25 years from now or 20
years from that way what is the
university life don't be like but I
wonder if you have if you can say
anything in this forum about about that
and what you could imagine with
something like a you know if I all
core course or you know what what starts
to happen if you really start applying
at a great grandma lives to to
disciplinary content at the higher
education level and if you if you don't
care to speak to that don't but I know
you had experience with people of all
ages all in our world run my test pretty
interesting advice not that yeah I mean
ah I mean it's incredibly fun to think
about this it difficult to see but I
really feel like watching this up swell
in hacker spaces and kind of the
enthusiasm for making in general that's
happening I I feel like it really could
shape the way we think about things the
way you determine the courses for next
semester how do you do that right the
things that you offer in the course how
do you get people well I mean the
d.school is doing this to like working
across disciplinary boundaries I think
that's part of it I think who you
recruit you know typically people who
lead classes have a certain background
can that change some you know i'm not
saying throw away all your professors
but think about community assets they
really are assets how can you tap into
and involve those folks i mean i would
ask the question whether your graduate
school professor whether your
kindergarten teacher by not doing this
work by not getting engaged first hand
with phenomenon and materials and
constructing in social areas what are
you giving up with anything that you're
trying to share or to teach and so it's
not throwing out the bath water but
trying to figure out in a biology
seminar or in mathematics seminar what
is it about the physical manipulation of
materials that can help us you know now
don't not only help us for those of us
who are at graduate school but what
about the ninety percent of kids who are
not going to go to graduate school
because they didn't think science or
math was for them and so where I think
it's important at the graduate school
level it's also important to just
generate that initial engagement and to
try to figure out what elements are
missing like this from what you might
all always already be doing I feel like
you see you see more
of students being driven by what they're
motivated by sometimes it's by who
they're working under the lab that
they're working in but I feel like you
see a lot more of that in graduate
school I think we could do a lot of
rethinking for undergrad stuff in that
realm in particular we should definitely
routines to donate their kind of
extending her body up a little bit it
seems that this could be an opportunity
for the nest brutish or for people who
cannot afford the top-of-the-line toys
or products and it's a great way to
teach them about how they can do these
two with lots of projects and kind of
good things for their kids or for the
family at a much lower cost so have
there been any thoughts to that never
last two you know can speak we need an
official what a society from a cost
perspective yeah I that is probably the
aspect of this work that excites me the
most I really see that as its biggest
greatest potential I think sometimes I
think make and maker faire get
unnecessarily dinged by you know saying
it's only high-tech it's only for guys
whatever it may be but I feel like if
you if it's really about this aspect of
making that is really tinkering truly
tinkering with whatever it is you're
working on that's Universal and and
having people be able to enter it that
this no matter where where they are or
what situation they find themselves in
it's a reverence for ideas right and I
feel like that's if we're talking about
what we want to do for society 20 years
from now I want to celebrate people's
ideas and that doesn't matter the their
background at all but they do need to be
able to participate an awesome software
being easier or harder to tinker with
them the physical toys like are there
ways that get software the easier to
tinker well I be designing for deeper
ability I me Mitchell actually wrote a
chapter about this yeah well I scratches
like 11 point example but I feel like
this you know that's a playground and
are there other such playgrounds or we
sort of restricted to that kind of
well I mean saw the tricky bit about
software is the people who design it no
it's so intimately and you're you're
trying to create a tool for others to
use but it's how to I don't know I feel
like some software it has tremendous
potential for this but I also know that
like clunky interfaces stifles I mean I
just I don't think we're there yet I
think we've got a lot how they've got a
lot of work to do in order to make let's
not talk about cost let's just talk
about the interface of the use for 3d
printers and programming for Galileo or
four for arduino and others i mean
there's such a high learning curve that
we can't do it right now on the floor in
a three even a three-hour interaction
the so scratch you know my storms all
these kinds of things are great but
they're also programming languages for
those built from the ground up to being
things that you can explore and when i
see you taking apart toys and
repurposing them that's different that's
a set of professionals who created
something for one purpose and yet when
you actually cut it open you can
understand it's working blown up to
adapt it for something else why is that
so argit software is it that like a
level Lex needs higher somehow I have
trouble believing that yeah no I don't
know that is that subversive quality to
taking something and reworking it that I
that I love so much but yeah how could
you build that into software that
capability that really well yeah I mean
people who love Linux they log you that
that does that but you know for the rest
of us not so much yeah yeah yes you
along that line potentially plate with
like maybe having a rebuilt save up to
get a Stanford CS 168 students bring out
game pre-built and and have tinkering
with the pre-existing social to us haha
let's give
like see that changing this variable
here changes speed or changing this
variable changes to totally all the ribs
well i think i think this point is in
every one of the cases that we
highlighted and talk about it is about
messing with the variables and so
whether it's a variable on the computer
screen or whether it's the variable of
how many batteries are connected to your
bulb the fact that you could change a
variable and then see an immediate
response to that is key and depending on
how the program is written or how the
toy is constructed you're not always
able to take just one quick step to see
a big change in the variable and so i
think that has a lot to do with how we
might conceptualize that type of
engagement yes to the question about the
underbridge but in the other direction
if you look at our corporations and you
deserve had a lot of collaborations of
the past are you seeing the difference
in the way of operations are talking
about rendering and creativity in their
own workplace from the ten years back
yeah usually I do and D school and now
we're getting we're fielding calls and
I'm i know my colleagues are feeling
calls from small and medium sized
corporations all across the country
wanting to be thinking differently about
how they approach the work that they do
but even more importantly how they
structure their own environment how they
have collaborative teams working
together how the organization is is
organized around ideas rather than
capacities and experience that you might
have as a graphic designer or program or
an engineer and so i think because we
see so many different people around the
table and these activities engage so
many different backgrounds and
experience levels we get a lot of i'm
having a lot of conversations lately
with corporations about that type of
organization structure they're even
asking us to develop the ropes course
for tinkering like what would it look
like to have either short-term t great
experiences for people and on the more
ambitious side bringing tinkering
studios directly into their their
companies and it's not just corporate
organizations we worked at the dali
lama's monks a couple of a couple of
years ago because their gaze who are the
orgonite community organizers and
educators in the Tibetan communities in
India we're looking for ways of thinking
about science and
slightly different way and looking for
ways of engaging the population in these
science experiences and so there's a
whole retooling there of what science
education means at that organizational
level this is moving towards more than
keeping or creation higher do you think
but in a new sir look more like
confession I think well maybe nothing
when people are hiring like art what are
they going to be looking for in terms of
tinkering will you tinker with stuff
when you go on an interview you do when
you interview with us but I would also
say people are looking I'm noticing more
and more people are wanting portfolios
actually that show evidence of making a
lot of the young makers that we work
with we're helping them develop those
things really talk about talk about what
you're doing share it you know and
whether physical objects are great but
yeah digital portfolios I think you're
gonna I think that's going to be part of
what's required yeah I mean besides
reconstructing vibrators and dildos
headgear yeah yeah we got really weird
let me just say that um for me probably
the most my favorite example of that i
should say we were celebrating chain
reaction cause and effect right and it
was again a februari love related do you
know that song the Love Machine I'm just
a Love Machine you know this is old
anyway if you look at the lyrics it's
really hilarious it's all about gadgets
and switches and electronics it's really
good anyway we were are the the
assignment so to speak when you came
into this tinkering studio we were
giving lots of people the opportunity to
build literal examples of love machines
and then we connected them all together
and set this whole thing off right
absolutely loved the analogies kind of
the metaphors that people were coming up
with for love we had things like
lovesick suffocation like really really
kind of bizarre like we had the fluffy
stuff too but you had some pretty
serious one and my favorite was an egg
that was in a vise hooked up to a slow
moving motor that slowly turned this
vise and this egg was actually getting
physically distorted in shape all of a
sudden it cracked and falls down on two
pieces of aluminum foil they had a tiny
crack in between them and the goo the
yolk from the egg completed a circuit
and like tripped off the next one which
was like a pickle and bubbles I mean
just crazy stuff yeah that's that's
following my favorite
you